♪
>> Jesse: ALL EYES ON MIAMI
TONIGHT AS OUR FAVORITE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
FINALLY GET INTO THE RING TO
SLUG IT OUT OVER THE ISSUES.
THE FIRST OF A TWO NIGHT
DEBATE SPLIT OVER 20
CANDIDATES AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP THINKS THIS ONE IS
GOING TO BE LOW ENERGY.
>> EVERYONE SAID I WILL BE
TWEETING.
I WILL ACTUALLY BE ON A
PLANE AND IT JUST SEEMS VERY
BORING BUT I'M GOING TO
WATCH IT BECAUSE I HAVE TO.
THAT'S PART OF MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S PART OF MY LIFE.
I DO WANT TO WATCH IT?
DO I WANT TO WATCH THESE
PEOPLE?
THAT'S A VERY UNEXCITING
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: EACH OF US HAS
COME UP WITH A PREDICTION
FOR TONIGHT'S DEBATE AND I
WILL GO FIRST.
SO I PREDICT THERE'S GOING
TO BE AUDIENCE INTERFERENCE.
I PREDICT THERE IS GOING TO
BE SOME HECKLER, SOME
SCREAMER.
>> Dana: CHANTING.
>> Jesse: SOMETHING WHERE
THE AUDIENCE MEMBER OR
MEMBERS TRY TO INTERRUPT AND
CAUSE A SCENE AND THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE HANDLED.
ALL RIGHT, KATIE.
YOU ARE NEXT.
>> Katie: EVERYBODY IS GOING
TO GET A FREE CAR AND FREE
COLLEGE.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Katie: THEY WILL SAY YOU
WILL GET THAT I THINK JOHN
DELANEY WILL GO AFTER OTHER
DEMOCRATS HE WILL BE ONE OF
THE FEW WHO DOES.
HE IS THE MORE MODERATE.
HE HAS BEEN SAYING IN
SPEECHES SOCIALIST POLICIES
ARE BAD FOR THE PARTY AND
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: HE WILL GET BOOED.
>> Katie: HE WILL GET BOOED
MAYBE AUDIENCE AND ZERO
QUESTIONS ABOUT LATE-TERM
ABORTION.
>> Jesse: ALSO CORRECT.
JUAN?
>> Juan: I GUESS THAT WOULD
BE A REPUBLICAN DEBATE,
KATE.
I THINK IT'S A BIG NIGHT FOR
ELIZABETH WARREN.
SHE IS THE ONLY ONE ON STAGE
WHO IS POLLS IN DOUBLE
DIGHTSZ.
IN TERMS EVER THE OTHER
PEOPLE I THINK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR GOING TO HAVE JULIAN
CASTRO REALLY SHOW UP.
I THINK THIS IS MIAMI.
HISPANIC AUDIENCE ON TELL
MUNSD DOUGH.
I THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HIM TO SHINE.
AND SECOND THING THIS GOES
BACK TO BIG SURPRISE HERE.
LESS TALK ABOUT TRUMP, MORE
TALK ABOUT POLICIES AND YOU
MAY SAY THAT'S BORING.
THEY WILL DISTINGUISH
THEMSELVES SOMEONE MAY SAY
TO ELIZABETH WARREN MAYBE
CLASH
.LASH
>>ASH
>> DH
>> Dana: BETO O'ROURKE WILL
GET A SECOND WIND.
TED CRUZ RACE.
WHAT DID HE RAISE
$50 MILLION.
$80 MILLION.
HE HAS A FOLLOWING.
HE, I THINK HE COULD FIND A
WAY TO GET A SECOND WIND
TONIGHT.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THAT
PREDICTION.
>> Greg: I PREDICT NOT A
SECOND WIND BUT A BROKEN
WIND.
THREE PREDICTIONS WAYFAIR.
>> Jesse: LIKE YOUR OMTs
CAN'T STICK TO ONE.
>> Greg: WAYFAIR WILL
PROVIDE BEDS TO ANYONE
WATCHING THIS DEBATE
INCLUDING LANDFALL THE
PARTICIPANTS.
PREDICTION FOR THE AUDIENCE.
HARD TIME TELLING THE
DIFFERENCE IDEOLOGICALLY
BETWEEN THE CANDIDATES AND
THE MODERATORS BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT'S ALL ONE FLAVOR OF
LEFTISM AND FINALLY MY BOLD
PREDICTION BETO WILL
ACCIDENTLY TAKE OUT
SOMEONE'S EYE WITH A
FLAILING ELBOW.
>> Dana: USE HIS MILLION
DOLLARS TO PAY THE FINAL.
>> Jesse: JUAN BROUGHT UP
ELIZABETH WARREN WHO IS FAR
AHEAD IN THE POLLS COMPARED
TO THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE ON THAT STAGE.
I THINK SHE IS GOING TO BE
ASKED ABOUT HERR INDIAN
HERITAGE.
AND I THINK SHE HAS TO BE --
YOU DON'T THINK SO?
>> Katie: I DO.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO
SAY HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
HANDLE THIS?
YOU DON'T THINK SHE IS GOING
TO BE ASKED ABOUT IT?
>> Katie: I DO.
>> Juan: I DON'T.
>> Jesse: I THINK SHE HAS TO
HAVE A DIFFERENT ANSWER.
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE HER
SOME ADVICE.
BECAUSE SHE HAS TO FLIP IT
BACK ONTO THE PRESIDENT.
SHE HAS TO SAY THE PRESIDENT
IS OBSESSED WITH MY FAMILY
TREE AND I CARE ABOUT
FAMILIES BEING SEPARATED AT
THE BORDER INDICATED
INDICATE WHY ARE YOU GIVING
HER ADVICE RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: THAT'S A GREAT
LINE.
>> Jesse: A BETTER LINE THAN
WHAT SHE SHE HAS BEEN
SAYING.
>> Greg: WE LEAD WITH THAT
TOMORROW.
>> Jesse: HER NIGHT TO
SHINE, WOULD YOU AGREE?
>> Dana: YEAH.
HER NIGHT TO SHINE.
>> Jesse: SHE HAS A LOT TO
LOSE TONIGHT.
>> Dana: SHE WILL MAKE IT TO
THE SECOND DEBATE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE, THE DNC
HAS DONE IS SAID TO GET TO
THIS FIRST DEBATE 65,000
SMALL DONORS.
TO GET TO THE NEXT DEBATE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE 130,000.
>> Jesse: YOU NEED MOMENTUM.
>> Dana: SHE'LL BE ABLE TO
DO IT.
MANY OF THE OTHERS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THAT YOU HAVE FEWER PEOPLE
IN JULY.
>> Juan: BY THE WAY, JESSE,
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ADVICE YOU ARE GIVING
HER.
JUST REMINDS ME I THINK YOU
WANT A DEBATE THAT'S MORE
LIKE THE REPUBLICAN DEBATE.
>> Jesse: I DO.
>> Juan: LITTLE MARCO, LYING
TED.
>> Jesse: I WANT PERSONAL
ATTACKS AND SHARP EXCHANGES.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE BORED BY
POLICY ON GLOBAL WARMING.
>> Katie: EXPECTATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE A LITTLE LET
DOWN.
>> Jesse: YESTERDAY YOU, I
MEAN I SAID NOT GOING TO
WATCH.
ARE YOU STANDING BY THAT?
>> Greg: BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY PEOPLE AND THEIR
TIME IS LIMITED, HOW CAN YOU
MAKE AN ASS OF YOURSELF.
HARD IT FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE
AN ASS OF THEMSELF.
BUT THEY DO HAVE LESS TIME
TO MARTIAL ONE CANDIDATE.
NEED THIS MUCH TO BECOME THE
NOMINEE IT COULD BE ANYBODY.
SWALWELL.
>> Dana: NEVER RUN OUT OF
REASONS TO RUN.
THEY RUN OUT OF MONEY TO RUN
RUN.
>> Jesse: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Katie: NOT ENOUGH TIME.
PEOPLE COULD SAY SOMETHING
WITHOUT ENOUGH CONTEXT AND
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT.
>> Juan: I HAVE GOT TO TELL
YOU, THE KEY IS NOT THAT
EXCITING, SO I AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT.
THE KEY IS INTRODUCING
YOURSELF.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THESE